he was giving a speech at a campaign
rally in was wazirabad in Pakistan when
a gunman reportedly opened fire
his footage appears to show the
politician being rushed into a car
before leaving the scene his supporters
say that he survived the shooting our
Asia correspondent Cordelia Lynch was at
that rally and gave us this update
we had probably about 10 minutes drive
from then at the moment I was led by
cameraman Duncan sharp on board he had
actually just been on top of the
container he'd been getting some shots
of Imran Khan addressing the devoted
masses it was a very heavy atmosphere up
there I saw women I saw children there
was a real sense of sort of jubilance
and buoyancy in the air and a few people
I spoke to had said that this felt
different this moment in Pakistan was
unlike anything they'd seen before
unlike anything even they had seen when
in mankind first took the power I've
been singing to one of his senior team
members who echoed this sentiment of his
that the genie was out the bottle but
the tide was turning that people were
sick at the economic ways of Pakistan
they're about to see something different
so we saw thousands of people on the
street a long line going perhaps up to a
mile long and then actually populated
that crowd there were people hanging
um
on various different buildings lots of
people taking photos a real sense of
optimism and yeah and the container
itself is not something I've experienced
but they were very tightly packed team
making the casino members downstairs
upstairs of course was where you get a
chance with him and he's been addressing
the crowds on a daily basis he starts
this long march between about between
one and two o'clock in the afternoon
till 10 o'clock at night then you do
camps a back to Lahore overnight and
then joins another staff of this March
they decide the name of the Long March
most of it had not been done on foot he
has been in the container he's had a
convoy of vehicle supporting him and the
strategy was that they would just gather
momentum and and gather support to try
and push for these early elections in
each Place uh that their rides at is
doing a lot stronger than what it's
actually been thought by the weekend
they'd be an Islamabad now they're
saying that to be a weak off and Marine
calm is telling me it is because they've
been surprised just by the strengths of
support here they're trying to
strategically make sure they
have the wind behind them and they're
able to put this pressure on government
that this was a really pretty rural area
that was deeply in support of the PTI
Imran Khan's party and that is uh partly
why uh this attack on his life has come
as a surprise there was real shock and
bewilderment in his team Duncan and I uh
were just there as one man was carried
through with a flooded search the women
I had been speaking to Atlant for about
30 minutes when I was asking what she
believed had happened she couldn't speak
there was just a ghastly silence a real
concern and at that point we didn't know
if the threat was still on board the
container or outside but as I say season
two a team member afterwards they were
adamant that the shooter and I am told
these were gunshots had come from inside
the bazaar so the streets surrounding
the container I have to say when I was
there you know having been on a
political party buses across the UK as
and we'll all be familiar with it does
feel very exposed so you're a top a bus
and there have been long worried about
assassination attempts on Imran Khan's
life and here he was for all to see he's
been spending hours every day on top of
that container and today an attack on
him and it appears according to what we
have been told by his team on three
others